can we hear more about the process of
writing the script and also how are you
writing it and then writing the web
series or you're not writing it at the
same time
sure so um i write them independently at
first i generally will start with the
feature script
because still uh still the the feature
film is still paramount
in this whole creative process um
you know it has to you have to have
something to hang everything on it's
like what i call the main event
um and so the web series um
is secondary to that and but it has to
be able to fit into this
to the film script what i mean by that
is like certain story elements have to
be parallel
um i then have um holders what i call
them
that there might be a scene the same
scene in the web series that's also in
the film
told from a different perspective so
that the audience
knows that this is the storyline
um you know and so it sounds very
complex and so what you need to do is
just
you need to start to map it out and what
i'll do is i will print out
each scene by scene and what i'll do is
i will tab out
the scene so it's a white page then and
keep everything very
you know um very separate and then what
i'll do then
is on a different color paper i will
then print out the web series
and and coral and collate them together
and then read them all one one
continuous story
to make sure that everything makes sense
then i'll start making edits from that
so again what i do is i will i will you
know chat out each scene
um you know have it all individually and
then i'll color code
with the web series so that i can
make sure that it's one cohesive story i
don't know if that makes sense does that
make sense to you
somewhat so with the 410 pages
how is that if i'm reading it is that
like is
part of it in the middle then we
stopping for the web series or i'm
just curious no it can actually read as
one long script
yes so i don't really so i know which is
which
uh by the by the color of paper and also
just by being the author of it too i
know which is which
um but it should be able to read as one
cohesive story
um you know when you're if you're
sitting down to read all 410 pages
and so when you're saying a main event
and now it's taking place in the web
series
from another perspective it just all
flows because now you know it's somebody
else's experience with that same
event yes like for instance um
the center of the billboard right so the
the
the characters go up on the billboard
and both the web series and also in the
film
but then once they get up to the
billboard it's different
right the radio station has what they
have to deal with
and the billboard centers have to deal
with what they have to deal with
and so that's like literally what i
would call a holder so that's like the
literally the start of the web series
and then part of the film you know then
what might what
might be happening like something
happens up in the billboard you know the
radio station
um jocks uh react
and then you see what is actually going
on the billboard so it's like that's how
it all works out it's a cause and effect
kind of play
right okay so when you would make a
change to the main part of the story
um take us through through the process
of then going back in and and
is it just you know at this moment in
the web series is a similar moment in
the script
and so just to go in and modify it yeah
and also too
it has to be something that is also
provocative as well
you know what i mean like you can't have
um
[Music]
something that doesn't provoke that
change
and what i mean by that is a matter of
um
if you change something in one you might
have to change something in the other
again because a lot of it's cause and
effect it's it's two different points of
view of the same story
but then the challenge comes in then you
shoot all this stuff and then you're in
the editing room
and you want to make a change so then
not only do you have to worry about
changing the film that it makes sense
now you have to change the web series to
make
sure it makes sense and that everything
actually works together
it's extremely complex very very complex
um
and so there's a lot of organization
that takes place there's a lot of work
that takes place and
everybody has to be on the same page and
everybody really
really needs to pay hypertension and
continuity
um because without good continuity like
this stuff will fall apart very fast
it becomes a mess you know and and the
reason that i feel that what we're doing
works is because we paid so much
attention to that
so you're releasing the web series
you've already released it all the
sections before the actual
feature film has come out we did yeah
and so but it's funny
is because people see the film want to
see the web series generally that's
generally how it's been happening
and so the people have been downloading
the web series then go to
billboardmovie.com
uh and then it's up on vimeo right now
it will
the web series will be released on other
digital platforms
but we chose that first because there
was a paywall there because obviously we
need to make money
um and uh because this content has just
cost us a lot of
freaking money um and um also we
went that model instead of the youtube
model uh just because
of um we wanted people to
buy into the story world not just
watch content yeah it's two different
ways of looking at things two different
mindsets you're going to to view content
then
interesting so if it was just if you had
all the parts of the web series
uploaded for free on youtube where there
was no paywall
for it you felt that people wouldn't be
as engaged
it just was content then i feel you know
just
more more noise out there like we do
have we do have short
aspects of the web series up on youtube
but it's pretty much for promotional
purposes
uh for the for the longer um episodes um
but it's just a matter of like one of
those decisions i had to make is like
where i wanted this to be
to live and to be seen um and so it
lives on vimeo
as is the portal that we're choosing for
right now will you put the feature film
um with a paywall online for people yeah
not right now because we're in theaters
um but we will
yeah well it's going to be you know it's
going to end up on itunes
uh amazon roku ad rise like all these
other portals and stuff
just not in the us but internationally
as well so with your tour are you going
overseas at all
i hope so um it's funny because in
search of it better overseas than i did
in the united states
i have more of a of a um european
sensibility than filmmaking i guess i
i didn't know that i it's not my
intention
it just ends up being that way um
because um
i guess like you know i'm okay with
things not being wrapped up in a pretty
bow
um and uh i'm more of a very
authentic storyteller uh and i don't
mind the rawness of things
um and so like for instance within
search of there was a lot of nudity in
it
um and um uh you know our britannic
society
has a hard time with seeing penises and
breasts i don't get it
i really don't or you know they find it
titillating which i think is a crock of
um and um you know so in europe it's not
a big deal
uh and so um you know i'm constantly
pushing the boundaries on things
um and storytelling i mean we got an r
rating so it wasn't you know
sex or anything like that it's just a
matter of like the human body it's kind
of weird
you